[Music]
kevin is with us in indianapolis hi
kevin welcome to the ramsay show
good afternoon sir it's pleasure to talk
to you you too what's up
uh i wanted to ask what your thoughts
are and maybe pros and cons of uh in
order to
kind of expedite step number two uh
allowing my credit card debt to go into
collections to hopefully settle for
a far lesser number
i would not do that unless you simply
have not got a way to pay the bill how
much credit card debt have you got
it's not astronomical it's about 14 000
um
it is
something i can feasibly pay off it's
just in order to do it comfortably and
still be able to put some money in
savings it's gonna
it's just gonna take a lot longer than
well then
i would like be honest
so we work with folks that are on the
verge of bankruptcy all the time
and they have no money and a hundred
thousand dollars in credit card debt and
there's no chance
that they're going to pay the bill that
they legitimately owe
if it goes into default then we show
them how to
settle that debt because it's their only
option
we do not do that
as a method of
getting out of debt more efficiently
because we believe that you owe the
money
you borrowed the money and you have the
ability to pay the money and you should
pay your bill
if there's any way you can and that's
your case
so no you should get six extra jobs and
pay this crap off by friday
it's only fourteen thousand dollars how
much do you
make uh about 60
yeah and you're only working 40 hours
well i'm only getting paid for 40 hours
um
i i would gladly take an extra job my my
work schedule is is a little uh
cramped uh to allow for an extra job but
but like i said i mean it is
it is an amount that i can pay off it's
just gonna and you should send me from
and you should you should sell some
stuff you should find some work that you
can do you can turn uber on and off you
can turn you can get really flexible
schedules delivering pizzas you can uh
talk to your boss about getting paid for
the overtime instead of not getting paid
for the overtime that you're working on
you you can do a have a garage sale
you've got days off you've got time
you're sitting in front of stupid
television go make some money it's only
14 000 and pay it back don't sacrifice
your integrity for that
and i kind of want you to be in pain
kevin just a little bit i want you to
feel the sacrifice because if not if
this feels like a shortcut and you go
man i negotiated it down got that paid
off let's do that again and you're back
on the ride and you're back in a cycle
of debt i want you to have a never again
moment and that's going to come from
taking the second job selling everything
going man never again am i going to be
in that tighten up the old budget the
belt
big time